other pieces on the board and eliminate
the exchanges batting here we get the
first move now and here we go and
waiting the first move E4 E4 you know
sometimes we have Sicilian when you want
Oh B6 when you want to win apparently
when you want to draw as white sometimes
E4 is the way to go because there are so
many forcing Ultra sharp lines that do
end in draw now this early B6 it it
doesn't have a good reputation for it uh
VAR yes I think definitely do that is
taking some risks here and there there
are some some games played in a database
in the current position after the move
Queen C7 about 40 games I see white can
in fact play the move Knight D5 try to
play Ultra aggressive and I think that
makes sense because black is still way
behind in development here so 95
attacking the Queen Bishop takes D5
Bishop takes D5 Queen E55 I've done it
by the way Knight D5 is on the board
Bishop Bishop E3 this is very very risk
getting for Duda can black take on D5
Bishop E2
now threatening Bishop F3 uh I'm not
saying I'm a pond Grabber but I'm not
signing up for this E5 is your only move
here I think really Bishop F3 E4 uh wish
F34 I think black is okay but white will
be better after the move Knight F5 I'm
still not so take only one Rook D1 and I
think black we can see why I can no good
compensation here Queen E5 immediately
by dude I wasn't interested and Bishop
takes D5 and Magnus saying Bishop E3 you
gotta take the Knight because Knight
takes B6 what
I was about to say Knight takes B6
apparently it's a blunder and now with
Knight F3 white is plus four
this might be a very quick game this is
very strange oh night and Duda just just
look to scans and he did not like that
move Knight F3
oh boy oh boy uh he missed it it was
over before it got started yeah
it's easy to miss backward moves always
yeah that but I look Knight takes oh
Knight takes B6 Queen A5 check that was
the nasty trick that he had set up
Knight F3 however oh my goodness Knight
C7 check
um
King has that Forks the king and Rook by
the way it goes to E7 oh dear me oh
blimey
that is just so bad yeah why it's going
to be at material and
we have the initiative conversation
right right you don't even need to rush
to take the rookie you can start out
with the move Queen D2 comparing a long
Castle I was about to say Bishop E2
Queen D2 queen queen D2 has my attention
because long castles and I could go
Queen D6 check
he took the Rook can't blame him for
that the King on E7 is just pathetic
Queen D2 castles born on sagging
uh yeah everything's wrong a horrible
position for Duda yeah he can play now
c4 yeah or even Queen D4 is very good
exchange I was gonna say queen D4 looks
great
it's not forget Magnus only needs a draw
of course he's gonna play to win this
game of course
uh Queen D4
uh
question for you is
n't for this line that Duda played in
the Sicilian early B6 on move two does
it have a name
and I don't know maybe there is a name
but I think definitely the smooth Queen
C7 I didn't like I would have preferred
something like E6 there right and try to
get you know some kind of a position
with Knight F6 yeah yeah uh but Queen C7
was just just way too risky to allow
Knight D5 E5 that invites Queen
Ace or queen C5 check
or A4 I mean anything everything looks
good for a while true that it does it
does A5 looks uh pardon me A4 looks very
very powerful
um to say Queen takes on D4 Knight takes
D4 B4 trying to shut things down but
this move A5 leaves this Pawn as a
permanent weakness
okay before we write uh final passage
for Duda remember he did get a pawn for
the exchange and he does have some
squares if he could just not just
develop material right so uh the bishop
A7 would be met by Knight C6
so
well does he have a chance to come back
a little bit that's what actually Mac
has played series of inaccurate moves
guys and Duda is actually he's okay now
and uh what yeah it was a position went
from almost plus six to right now it's
like you know less than plus one for
white no kidding G5 I still I mean
Bishop takes Ace do you think Magnus is
relaxed already
I I think from magnus's point of view
he's probably thinking I've done
everything properly and well if you
hadn't told him your last few moves were
inaccurate uh Magnus he wouldn't believe
you he would say I've just won the pawn
on A6 I'm cruising I don't know what
you're talking about so Rook A2 but
going from plus six to plus 0.5 that's a
big well that's a big change he just he
just doesn't know it I mean because he's
thinking and now just Knight takes B6
for Duda and then Rook B8 pick up the B6
spawn and I see some uh you know serious
compensation he played it the wrong way
though he he he attacked the bishop and
permitted it
permitted the bishop to retreat to E3
yeah Rook B8 was inaccuracy because that
A5 Pawn is actually going to remain on
the board now precisely and I'm not sure
why
what Bishop okay sorry the bishop on A8
is hanging so you can't capture it twice
but Bishop E3 might have been far more
confounding absolutely or even Bishop
Bishop C5 check uh the force the D6 and
then go Bishop E3 because in some of
these lines Rook will come to A7 with
with a check absolutely that was just a
big Advantage for white and now after
Knight D4
and Mac was may not have an advantage
but he also doesn't risk to lose this
rate and he only needs a draw exactly
um
although again I mean now I feel the
inaccuracies are beginning to pile up
now it's less and he's one and a half
minutes behind on the clock I mean we
thought dude I was gonna resign in less
than 20 minutes oh for sure sure it
looked like it was move eight or
something that dude was looking and
discussed at the move Knight F3 and uh
at that moment we thought it was plus
four or we were told by the engine it
was plus four now he's fighting back
yeah Wesley drew his game against dick
okay he's trying to secure his third
place but his mvl uh putting pressure
lost by the way that might be an
inaccurate information oh apologize for
that I would have to check
oh my oh my
okay and mvl
mvl is still playing unclear about equal
position Okay jump back in we just have
to move Bishop F3 by Magnus and he keeps
spoiling things
already very slightly better exactly
yeah
Rook B6 he's even included the move B3
by the way
I'm not 100 sure you needed to include
B3 because that does ensure that white
yeah and then more pawns coming off the
board and this H4 is a critical move
this is a very strong move because you
get rid of your age weak H Pawn and now
you exchange more pawns exactly and this
is going to give Magnus a lot more
drawing chances exactly if only there
are more pieces on the board dude I
would definitely have a chance but well
I can only imagine in the playing Hall
the Polish audience is holding their
breath
can the Polish fighter I I'm using that
term because he has a handle as the
Polish fighter on chess.com
can he snag this game Rook takes B2 here
that is a that's a confounding ending
bishop and four pawns versus rook and
two pawns the double pawns are actually
okay yes because uh that makes it easy
to trade but the the straight up Bishop
versus two pawns versus Rook if there
was only a bishop in two pawns I
remember uh girovich beating Larry
Christensen with the bishop in two Pawns
wow yes that can happen that can happen
against the pawns are far Advanced yes
and yeah you have a chance but I think
here it should be comfortable draw for
Magnus do you think that Duda should be
trading Rook through or do you think he
should play E5 I'm happy he was shaking
his head like how do I get here he's not
happy that yeah from the opening we we
read due to his last rights E5 in
keeping the Rook on the board
yeah I think this is the best chance for
him to play five but he played Bishop
B6 keeping the but we're about to see B3
that's an improvement for white that's
definitely the the pawn is no longer on
a dark Square
and uh
maybe black wants to create four passers
so D5 E5 not quite sure what the move
Rook A4 does I was more interested in
Rook going to the A8 Square so that I
could come across I think he wants to
play it oh there you go he wants to play
B4 and for some exchanges
oh Bishop uh blindness Bishop B3 Rook no
I'm not blind Bishop B3 Rook if uh three
okay yeah I I was thinking Bishop takes
Rook A7 is met by Bishop to D6 and
you're not you're not forcing a trade of
Rooks
B4
I mean I guess dude I could play Bishop
D6 right away to avoid exchanges make
and I still try to push with E5
yeah I would uh
the only hope here is that Magnus goes
into some deep time trouble and then
makes a big wonder by the way I'm not a
fan of this move Bishop B6 because Rook
a a threatens maybe winning and The Rook
B8 is a winning thread because that
bishop and Rook would be tied up to the
B2 so he needs to full Play Bishop C5
Bishop C5 to play Bishop C5 yes Bishop
C5 Rook A5 Rook B4 oh yeah and we we get
the ending that it seems like Duda has
been trying to avoid
yeah I don't think he can keep avoiding
the exchange exactly
by the way Bishop C5 would run into Rook
D3 as well right and do this down to 10
seconds by the way Bishop C5 Rook D3 and
uh we can agree a draw right away Rook
D3 okay five oh he missed it Magnus did
I mean this is also
if I draw white has to try hard to lose
this
where there's a whale there is a way
Rook to C7 and just wait
the problem is G5 upon is weak and it's
going to be difficult to activate the
Kink and now you can play even Rook H6
Rook H6 followed by Rook G6 I like that
uh keep an eye on that g E6 Pawn exactly
I like that very much that would uh by
the way is the clock a factor yet
um
wow okay it feels like to me that dude
has achieved more or less the maximum he
can play D5
pardon me yes D5 followed by D4
and
well okay G4 check
D4 is time to take the pawn
it's very hard for him to create a pass
Pawn
and I see that mvl won his game
because I think that allows them to be
able to catch Wesley in a tie for third
and this was the ending I was asking you
about for King
and Rook versus the bishop and the two
Pawns
I have seen uh again uh not Dimitri
garvich the other garbage and I'm trying
to remember its name
thank you so much
yeah Michael gervich and what Michael
did was very clever he he was passing
around for 40 moves
and got Larry thinking then he would
Advance upon play another 40 moves and
torture torture uh poor Larry but D4
okay what does the table base tell us
it's it shows it's just equal here but
in time travel it's
the idea is if you play D3 I have King
E3 I think now he needs to just stay on
the fifth rank this is yeah to stay on
the fifth rank now yeah that's the
problem but this move this move
threatened D3 check followed by E3
and what about King C4 and D3 King C4
Rook H4 now I'm sorry
there's a moment of nervousness there
as again Duda dude is the one with
chances obviously well two seconds for
Magnus so wow
King C4 and it's getting scary D3 check
it is winning now the table based Talent
is telling the jump it's a win but no
Bishop G3 was a miss
Bishop D6 was winning
oh my God it's still winning no are we
gonna see a playoff
winning to a draw that's what table uh
bass is telling me
wow wow
anything can happen in Blitz okay what
does your intuition tell you and I'll
see I think we're gonna be a playoff
s bar yes I think it should be a draw
with the correct defense here
and let's see three seconds for two you
gotta keep the Rook on D3 so if E3 comes
you can take
wow
how does white claim it during the
situation you have to yeah you say to
the Arbiter uh I'm claiming 50 moves now
if you're draw claim is unaccepted then
your opponent gets extra time was that a
mistake
no I think it's still fine still fine
King C3 now King C3 but there were three
or four times
no Rook d8 check
oh
magmas how many seconds this Magnus has
10 seconds dude has five
whoa whoa whoa whoa and
it's incredible that Duda had a win more
than once here
Rook I was about to say Rook check and
Rook to E4 Rook to D5 sorry again
Rook to D7 yeah Rook D7 Rook D3 here
yeah D3 right yes okay don't lose your
Rook
Rook check Rook D7 King C4 that's right
oh my gosh
and playing this position with no time
on the clock and defending I want to say
heroically this is a really impressive
play by Magnus Rook
so he needs to keep the king cut off for
as long as he can exactly we're up to B5
pushes E3 he has Rook A3 right
forcing or down until one second one
second
both of them at various moments there
just went down to one second
imagine if one of them Flags if Magnus
Flags this oh my goodness
I'm predicting playoffs everybody you
heard it here first
still table based still showing intro of
course still showing a draw but now the
threat is E3 Magnus found
one of the drawing moves
he's playing very accurately
with almost no time no time and by the
way this looks like a three-time
repetition I feel like I've seen this
this this position before but it's hard
to claim that so
for sure it is impossible and that's
that's bad draws the game oh oh wow
do that yeah he came back from a
terrible opening and nearly pulled it
off I was wrong my almighty God serves
this tournament hotels I I caught a
playoffs Magnuson finally relaxed and
take a deep breath
wow and I just got a quad Magnus